The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open CourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Rasheed, why don't you
give us that point that you
were making to me about DARPA.
RASHEED: Yes, so DARPA relies
very heavily on this program
manager structure.
So they give these program
managers a lot of power
and a lot of leeway to
do whatever they want.
But they have-- they have to
have a very distinct vision
from the outset,
like really when they
start to be able to do things.
And so I was concerned that
these program managers were
going to basically be
coming from the same places
over and over again, and so
have very similar visions.
And you're going to
be able to miss out
on a lot of
different talent that
exists outside, or a lot
of different new projects,
or new fields, maybe,
just like you're talking
about-- these new
collaboration between biology
and kind of humans and computer
science, things like that.
But that was really
my main concern,
was program managers
weren't being chosen as--
equitably isn't the word,
but that the selection
process of these program
managers was actually--
might be too narrow.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: But
they do get visionaries.
STUDENT: Sometimes.
I mean, I think we
mentioned that they only
got white males [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
OK, so I'm going
to move us to Tammy Carleton.
And Tammy's big
perception about DARPA
is this vision perception, that
that's a critical factor that
makes DARPA different.
And there is a
process that DARPA
has developed for this radical
technological visioning.
And essentially, she argues that
there's six stages that they
use to kind of get there.
First, recruitment
of great talent--
and the talent, they
hear about talent
from this DARPA network,
which is now quite huge.
Because all of the people that
get DARPA contracts and awards,
they stay in this
kind of DARPA family.
And typically, researchers
love to work for DARPA.
Because working on DARPA-hard
problems is really intriguing.
So that's a community that
tends to know each other,
and be in communication,
as well as
the community of former DARPA
program managers and officials.
So a lot of the talent
comes through that network,
which kind of knows
what's going to work.
So the recruitment and the
vision get united in a way,
in that recruitment process.
Then comes the stage of
the vision formulation.
The program manager
has got to figure out
what they're going to do with
their four or five years.
And they've got to
formulate a radical vision,
a right/left vision,
what's going to come out
of that pipeline, and what's
the fundamental research that
going to get me there.
And it's driving for
that breakthrough that's
the organizing proposition.
Then, they've got to
go through defining
a program and its launch.
Often, they will
have a workshop,
an invitation-only
workshop, where
they'll assemble 25, 30, 40
of the kind of best thinkers
on a project area, and
meet for a day or two days.
I've watched one of those,
which got held up at MIT as part
of the beginnings of creating
this Biological Technologies
office.
And they brought in just
an amazing collection,
from MIT and from
elsewhere, of thinkers
about what some of
the early projects
might be to achieve some
of these capabilities.
So the Deputy Director
of DARPA came up,
and kind of helped
run this workshop
and think this through.
The office wasn't
set up for a while
until the next DARPA
director, but it really
helped contribute
to that portfolio.
And it was a really
serious effort.
So the program manager
develops a portfolio approach
of standing up a
series of groups
that are going to be working on
this, and inter-relating them.
And the program
manager is also going
to be responsible for making
this technology transfer.
So in other words,
it's not enough just
to do something cool.
You've got to move it into
the implementation stage.
And how is that going to happen?
So the program manager
has got to undertake
all of these various steps.
So the criteria for
being DARPA hard
is that the project has
to be technologically very
challenging.
It's got to extend beyond the
current limits of technology
and knowledge.
Otherwise, they don't
really want to do it.
It's got to be actionable,
which means it can be made.
It can be built.
It can be produced.
So if it can't be, why do it?
You've got to be
able to demonstrate
that it's actionable.
Typically
multidisciplinary-- that it's
going to draw on a variety
of areas of expertise.
It's got to be far reaching.
It's got to change things.
It's got to be very
ambitious at a big scale.
"Don't do little things" is
kind of a DARPA sub-rule.
And various techniques
to flesh out the vision
include those
expert-only workshops,
and a proof of concept effort.
Sometimes, if it's some
idea that looks promising,
they'll do what DARPA calls
a "seedling," just put
a little money on it,
and let somebody play
with it, a real
thinker play with it,
and see what it might
materialize into.
So they've got that
seedling capability.
There is no training system
for program managers.
They don't go through
any kind of training.
They just arrive.
And they kind of learn
from other program managers
what they're supposed to do.
So there's a very strong
kind of DARPA culture
about how it operates, that gets
communicated by word of mouth
and kind of learning by doing.
And it's informal exchange,
but there is a very strong kind
of operating rules set.
DARPA program
managers really have
to be quite entrepreneurial.
And Martine, you were
raising this earlier.
They've got to stand up
a whole new territory.
And to do that,
they've got to be
highly entrepreneurial about
how to bring that about.
And the decision to stand
up a vision program--
this is not set up
through peer review.
There isn't consensus
decision-making at DARPA.
That program manager has got
to have a really strong vision,
and it's got to get
really organized.
And then it's got to
withstand the office director
and then the DARPA director
really tearing through it,
and really analyzing it.
So once you get that,
though, the approvals
can be very fast,
once the decision is
made to stand something up.
And that the program
manager really is--
to go back to that term
that you liked, Steph--
a vision champion.
They've got to champion this
vision and make it happen.
That's what the program
manager has got to do.
So DARPA starts with division.
That is not how
industry operates.
That's not how other
government agencies operate.
Industry works largely on what's
called a "stage gate system."
So industry is going
to want to do typically
more incremental
kind of advances,
because the advances can snap
onto markets that it's already
got, and economic opportunities
that it already sees,
and technologies that it's
already starting to explore.
So it's typically
going to want to do
more incremental advances.
And it's only going to do those
incremental advances if they
can optimize them economically.
So an industry R&D
project has got
to go through a series of
stage gates, which essentially
is a way of tearing down
a large menu of stuff
and getting to the most
economically optimal.
Industry stage gate process
is not a technology visioning
system.
It's not deciding on
a vision and doing
whatever is necessary
to get there, which
is the way DARPA operates.
It's a much more limited set
of procedural stage gates
that a technology idea
has got to go through.
So DARPA just working
on a very different kind
of organizational model from the
way in which things are done,
either at other agencies
or within industry.
And starting with
this vision up front
is a really interesting
organizational idea,
that you all should kind
of keep in mind when you're
operating out there, and
setting up your own companies,
and doing your own startups.
So Max, you've got
Tammy Carleton's piece.
MAX: Right.
The key step within
Carleton's five steps
that I thought was
most interesting
was the fifth one,
technology transfer, which
is supposed to bridge the R&D--
the valley of death,
as it were, that
enables a different scientific
idea to be commercialized,
and to actually affect people
all over the world, eventually.
While reading, I
kind of realized
that DARPA seems like they have
a pretty decent organization.
They get things done
relatively efficiently.
They have a lot of money.
Why is it they have--
and I actually just
decided to start googling,
to try to figure out if DARPA
had done anything related
to fusion.
And I couldn't find anything.
So I'm curious, why not?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, actually,
DARPA deferred on
energy technologies
to ARPA-E, when
ARPA-E got stood up,
because DARPA views
ARPA-E as a compatriot.
And ARPA-E interestingly, has
done some extremely interesting
work on fusion.
STUDENT: I know Lockheed
[INAUDIBLE] fusion--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
MAX: Yeah, but
Lockheed Martin's--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
they have the Skunk Works.
MAX: They do.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And DARPA's
done an enormous amount of work
with the Skunk Works over
time, including stealth.
MAX: Granted, yes-- they
definitely have a facility,
and they definitely have
the project managers.
I just feel that
it's a bit of an area
outside of their expertise.
They're going to accidentally
make it fly and stuff.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And look-- another issue
for DARPA is-- remember,
these technologies have
got to get stood up
in the lifetime of the project.
MAX: Yeah, five years.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Like
a five year project.
So if you can't do
it within five years,
it's very hard to put
it on the DARPA agenda.
MAX: Well, you mentioned
that some of the projects
would get handed off to
other project managers.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
MAX: So that's how long
a manager lasts, right?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
MAX: But it's not always
how long a project lasts.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
Sometimes, there can be
intergenerational transfers.
And then Licklider developed
a different kind of system.
He created a community
that kept continuing
with the same kind
of ethos, working
on that same set
of agenda items,
working them down
one after another,
and making progress year
after year on each of them.
So that's a
different kind of way
that DARPA is going
to be organized.
But typically, once
the program manager
leaves who had the
vision, their job
is to get that implemented
in their, in effect,
DARPA lifetime.
And if they haven't,
then it's hard for DARPA
to continue that,
which we could view
as a weakness of the program.
On the other hand, you
could view it as a strength.
MAX: Yeah, because then
they make sure that things--
that if they are
working, then they keep--
they may proceed with
it, or they pass it off
to someone else.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
MAX: So speaking of Licklider,
actually, while I was reading,
I noticed that Licklider had
mentioned that he heavily
relied on standardized tests
when picking candidates,
so like that recruitment
of great talent.
Given that literally
everyone in this room
has experience with standardized
testing, and at least
I can't speak for everyone,
but I don't like it very much.
I wonder--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] two tests.
MAX: Which two?
It was ACTs.
STUDENT: One was
like a psych test,
and the other one was
like a [INAUDIBLE]..
STUDENT 1: GRE.
We did the GRE, it said.
STUDENT: Well,
there's another one,
but it seemed like
a psychology test.
I'm not sure.
STUDENT 1: So I think
that she mentioned
that he was the only one who
asked for test scores at all.
And one was the GRE,
which is kind of weird.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Remember,
he was a psychologist coming out
of the testing world.
So that's probably
part of the reason.
MAX: I'll chalk it up to
[INAUDIBLE],, because there's
only so much a standardized
test can tell you.
They won't really tell you
how you work with people.
They won't tell you
anything about how
you work on anything that's
not related to, I don't know,
math or literature.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: He did come
up with a pretty talented team,
though.
MAX: Yeah, that's true.
STUDENT: I mean, you get
pretty far on psychology tests,
especially when it
comes to intertia.
Because you have to figure
out, for really good visionary
leaders, what
they'll figure out is
they're intellectuals,
introverts, extroverts,
and they have a supporting
side to their psyche.
And they're kind of like
the avatar of team groups.
So it's pretty good for if you
want to find out good leaders.
And I know it's been pretty
effective in manageent theory
when you use psych tests.
It's also really
good to figure out
who is going to be a
really good scientist,
because it's usually
highly introverted
and comes up with new insights
that doesn't follow the crowd.
So I can see why
that's important.
The GRE might be, but
also, if your score is low,
but if you've come out
with a good body of work,
then they can probably
assume that you
are pretty smart, even
if you didn't do well
on standardized tests.
STUDENT 2: Because I'm
looking up her LinkedIn.
And it says that she has-- her
background is in communication.
And then she got a Master's
in Public Relations.
And then she did a PhD in
Mechanical Engineering Design.
But that must have been back
in the day when the D School
at Stanford accepted
non-engineers
and non-scientists,
because now they don't.
So it would be curious to
think about the ways in which
her background, in particular,
might give her that insight
that an engineer might not have
about this particular field,
going back to the question of
multidisciplinary great groups.
But I don't know to what
extent, for example,
someone like me might be
accepted in maybe Lilly's lab.
LILLY: One of the most
famous women in my field
has an undergraduate
degree in German.
So you never know.
STUDENT: Lloyd Blankfein, the
CEO of J P Morgan, I think--
his degree's in history.
And he almost
barely didn't pass.
He said he still
gets nightmares,
because he didn't fulfill
all the requirements.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
All right, so we're
going to move out of the testing
world back to the DARPA world.
MAX: Sure.
So one of the things
that Carleton pointed out
was that as DARPA has aged, so,
too, have its project managers.
Even though they cycle between
new managers every four or five
years, the average age of the
managers that they would pick
was going up steadily.
So I'm curious if
anyone has thoughts
on what the effect of that would
be on their managerial ability,
or on DARPA's
direction as a whole.
STUDENT: Could you
repeat that first part?
MAX: Yeah.
So the average age of
the project managers
has been increasing,
as DARPA has--
STUDENT: What's the average age?
MAX: I don't
remember the numbers.
STUDENT: Is it 27?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No,
it's a lot older than that.
STUDENT: It's a lot older?
MAX: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: One
of the reasons, Max,
may be that it's--
I mean, watching MIT, it's
very hard for younger faculty
to walk out of the place
before they get tenure.
It's hard enough to walk
out once you get tenure,
but it's impossible to walk
out before you get tenure.
And because you're
establishing a whole--
your research portfolio and
your whole researching system,
and it's very hard
to walk out of that.
In addition, when you go to
DARPA, you've got a conflict.
Once you've worked there,
you have a conflict
of interest with DARPA.
You're not going
to be able to deal
with the agency for a
certain period of time.
So if they happen to be
funding your research before,
they're not going to be able to
continue funding your research
once you've worked there.
So it's gotten more
complicated for DARPA
to recruit at the
university level.
It's gotten a lot
more difficult.
So the route between
MIT and DARPA,
frankly, used to be a
lot easier to manage.
And when I look at my colleagues
here who have gone to DARPA,
they are more typically
fairly far along,
and very assured about their
career, and their research
foundation, and their writing.
They've done that
stuff, and they
can take a three
or five year break,
and get that really
big, visionary thing
that they've wanted to
work on forever done
when they go to DARPA.
But it's harder when
you're trying to administer
a whole research portfolio.
Again, with the IPA
authority, you've
got a certain freedom to come
back to your organization
and keep the
day-to-day stuff going.
But it's still not simple.
So that may be one
part of the reason
that you tend to get somewhat
older faculty than they
probably used to
at the beginning.
STUDENT 1: Licklider
wasn't especially young
when he was the director.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Right, he wasn't young.
STUDENT 1: Or the
project manager.
So I think age does affect the
perspective that you bring in.
But having older people
isn't a bad thing.
I think in the tech
world, it's seen
as like if you're
not young and hip,
you're going to be out of touch
with what's going to work.
But I don't know if that's a--
I think the points
that Bill made
about having to kind of
establish yourself and figure
out what your vision is, you
have more time when you're
older to have a vision.
LILLY: Yeah, and
perspective as well.
Just thinking about advisors
I've had over the years,
and younger or newer
advisors versus more
established advisors--
they definitely
have a different perspective.
And yeah, NASA is actually
having the same phenomenon,
with having directors who are
progressively older and older.
So that's very
sim-- they can't--
it's very difficult
to draw someone away
from a mid-range career if
they're being very successful,
and having success
getting grants.
And it's hard to get them into
administration or directorships
or management.
STUDENT: What would
the difference
between young and
older directors be?
LILLY: In general, actually,
the more established and older
advisors that I've had
have had a lot more
perspicacity with respect to
what projects are worthwhile,
actually, or--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Through long experience,
you're suggesting, because
they've seen a lot.
LILLY: Yeah, that's
the impression I get.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
Next, how about
another question?
MAX: Sure.
All right.
So Carleton
mentioned that DARPA,
in order to save time
when they are trying
to develop these
projects, they try
to discourage consensus, which
I didn't really see as a--
I think it was the second,
the next slide you have.
Yeah.
So I understand
why, because then it
ensures that whatever
you're trying to develop,
it gets done quickly.
But just because it
gets done quickly
doesn't really mean
that it gets done right.
So I guess I was curious
what people thought on that,
specifically that decision.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It's a
very interesting point, Max.
And actually, ARPA-E--
and we'll talk about it
when we get to ARPA-E
and the energy class,
but ARPA-E does have a process.
It's a much smaller agency, so
it's 300 million, not 3 billion
like DARPA.
So it's like a big DARPA
office, sizable DARPA office,
one of its five or six offices.
So ARPA-E does have
a consensus process.
They bring in-- they call
them "project directors"
but they're program managers.
And that community,
really, you have
to present your vision
to that community.
And that's a very tough-minded
group, and a very sophisticated
group.
And the director is quite
sophisticated at ARPA-E
historically, as well.
So they did a variation on this.
At DARPA, it's much more,
convince your office director,
and then the office
director will work with you
on convincing the
director of DARPA.
It's a simpler, more
straightforward process.
You do get support
from other program
managers, who will have a lot
of advice and ideas for you.
So it's a pretty
supportive operation.
Nobody's in competition
with each other.
They're there to
help each other,
so that's a positive,
although again, they're
competing to achieve
their vision.
And everybody kind
of knows who's
getting their vision
done, and kind of who is
in trouble with their vision.
So that's kind of
known and understood.
There's a certain kind of
competition in that way,
but it's not a direct one-on-one
competition with each other.
But at ARPA-E, there is more
of a consensus decision making.
And Luyao when she was
telling us about Xerox PARC,
remember, your whole discussion
about the dealer process
and having to bring your idea
to the whole team sitting around
on beanbags, who
would tear it apart--
that's kind of a
consensus process.
It's a definite,
tough-minded review process
that DARPA doesn't
really quite have.
So there may be strengths and
weaknesses in both models.
Max, what do you think on that?
MAX: Yeah, I could see there'd
be strengths and weaknesses
to both.
But it just feels if you have
less consensus, than you have--
if you have fewer
people that are trying
to discuss these
ideas, then there
might be some critical
flaw that you might not--
that you might just miss, just
because there are fewer people
with more diverse experiences.
Of course, if you have a decent
idea of the science behind it,
and it's not
something as untested
as fusion, for
example, then I could
see it working pretty well.
I mean, if you had
to do that for--
I could see it having problems
with something untested
like stealth.
But apparently,
they made it work.
So maybe they're
passing my expectations.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
Silicon Valley perspective,
like it's a pretty
common mantra to say
you want to have an idea
that people kind of say
is not a good idea.
Because the idea is,
if you're coming up
with something that's
pretty innovative,
most likely people
won't agree with it,
or it doesn't make sense,
or you have an insight
that other people don't get.
Also, if you're an
expert, you probably
know some things that
other people don't know,
that you'd have to bring them up
to speed on, especially if it's
in a completely new area.
And so the history
has been, they're
just saying that for new
fields, who is the expert?
It wouldn't be a PhD,
because the field
hasn't been invented yet.
It's this person who just
started working on it.
So Bill Gates was an expert on
software for personal computers
before that even became a thing.
So it's very common
to-- consensus
is actually really bad, because
you put down these ideas based
on new insights.
So.
LILLY: Yeah, and another
issue with consensus
is you have to
assume, or you have
to have a group in which all
members have the personality
type that they will concede
to someone else's idea
to get consensus,
even if it's not
their pet project
or their favorite.
You know what I mean?
Some people aren't disposed
to do that, no matter what.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: About a
closing thought on this, Max?
MAX: Sure.
So overall, I feel
that DARPA seems
to have been a
pretty great success.
They've made lots of
really cool projects.
They do it very quickly.
Not sure how cheaply they
do it, but they get it done.
And because of that
continued success,
I feel that that's
probably why they continue
to get so much funding.
I really try to emphasize that
technology transfer aspect,
because it ensures that the
technology that they develop
isn't just it's a nice, new
toy for the military to have.
It ensures that whatever
they make, from the internet,
GPS, et cetera, that
everyone can use it,
and that it makes our
entire society better.
So I guess that's pretty
much just why I like DARPA.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Great.
There's a lot of MIT folks and
people saying, what do you do?
All right, let me do a quick
wrap up of today's class.
So we did Mitch Waldrop's book.
And I really wanted
to kind of portray
the governmental role in
supporting the earlier stage
of the evolution of computing.
It was a proving ground
for new concepts,
and designs, and architectures.
The Defense Department
created an initial market
for a lot of the new
products, and services,
and in fact, whole industries.
This greatly expanded university
research capabilities,
the computing revolution.
And it was done to further
governmental missions.
But it had, obviously,
dramatic societal effects.
So it featured
governmental agencies
playing a pretty central role.
DARPA, as we discussed
was critical,
but some of the others
were necessary and needed.
And the governmental
agency sponsored
these industry-university
collaborations
that led to great strength
in the university side,
and focus areas around them.
So in the reading that
we did from the textbook,
the central point
here was that DARPA
was uniquely able to combine an
innovation institutional role,
as well as a great
groups innovation
at the face-to-face
level kind of role.
That's a remarkable
accomplishment.
And then DARPA's ability, as
we talked about in that reading
as well, to innovate
in a legacy sector,
to do a frontier sector
like IT, but also
innovate within a legacy sector,
and do things like stealth,
and UAVs--
that's a pretty
fascinating organization,
that's flexible,
and interesting,
and able to do great stuff.
Glenn Fong's piece
was really about DARPA
playing the central
institutional mobilization
role for the IT revolution.
And Tammy Carleton's
piece really
told us about this kind
of central importance
of technology visioning as a
key modus operandi, that DARPA
been able to operate in.
Any closing questions?
Good luck with your
paper outlines.
Let me know if you
have questions.
And I look forward to
seeing you on Tuesday.